in my years fighting crime I've learned
one proof that every villain is the hero
of his own story
you better than this closure that's the
problem fighting for truth and justice
the battle never end when does it stop
when there's no more crime
we were poor with easy
I won't hurt you unless I have to
hope isn't enough to save the world none
of us
and either with me or against
we both knew it'd come to this was only
a matter of time I'll try to make it
painless
hey everybody is Charles we got all
kinds of crazy injustice cutscene to
break down let's do it a lot of you also
requested that I talk about that suppose
at Arkham game leak so I added that to
the end of the video but this is so cool
so this is picking up right after the
last game left off and there explains it
because they didn't want to repeat the
batman be superman thing from the first
game that they brought in Brainiac as
the new villain with the society being
like the new regime type organization
that Batman has to rise up and fight
because a lot of his old alliances like
they say shattered alliances in the
trailer have either become collaborators
or victims of the regime so basically
like all the teams are getting shattered
everybody's getting mixed up and then
Brainiac is coming in with this new
society group so if you're new to the
channel you have no idea what's going on
I do DC videos every week for the game
stuff to be sure to subscribe to get
everything because there's a whole bunch
of injustice coming I'm doing a giveaway
that I'll explain at the end of the
video to the other big twist the dark
side teaser at the end is something else
too he's seeing all this chaos and
taking advantage of it so he just like
one of the playable bonuses there's also
a couple other characters that you don't
see in that via premium skins like Jon
Stewart Power Girl reverse-flash and
this is kind of crazy but it seems like
a no-brainer because it's nether realm
ed boon basically says that they're
putting scorpion in as DLC so you can
actually play with the Mortal Kombat
character in the injustice game but if
you don't remember the story from the
end of the first injustice game what
happened is is that the good superman
from the alternate universe came in and
helped defeat regime superman this evil
version of superman this is like the
full big cut scene from the end of that
game so enjoy your reign is over
[Music]
you won't terrorize these people any
longer there is the only thing these
people understand one day you'll learn
you'll have to kill me no not even you
there's been enough killing
[Music]
Superman's accomplices have been rounded
up or turned themselves in the next job
is restoring civil order the
transitional government has its hands
full we're here if they need help thanks
but no the people need to know they're
in control not us so you haven't changed
your mind I respect the president's
offer but I don't belong in government
none of us do you think Batman as a
future here crime and corruption will
return Hollywood have called me a
pessimist I'm just being realistic and
you're Superman he'll stand trial they
all will he was right to know about what
put in the same position I might have
done the same thing we never know what
we're truly capable of I hope for your
world's sake you never find out
[Music]
just keep this in yeah if something ever
happens and you do lose it I'm coming
for you
you'll have to get online
[Music]
so they put him in prison and this is
basically where you pick up at the
beginning of this trailer here where
he's getting out of prison so it's like
okay I'm out my regime has freed me and
now it almost looks like the Damian
Wayne Robin is going to be going up
against his version of Batman they're
not getting too complicated with
alternate universe characters here so
it's basically everybody's friends
turning on each other in a way that you
didn't see in the first game because
they're like we saw Batman's by Superman
we don't want to repeat that out right
it has to be something that's much more
compelling and what's more compelling
than Damian Wayne deciding that his
father is not extreme enough that's why
I loves his character so much but this
is obviously like a much older version
of the character than you see in the
animated movies in the cartoons they
actually just started that super son's
comic if you're real big fan of the idea
of young Damian Wayne teaming up with
the son of pre-crisis Superman John Kent
so the other thing about this but I'm
wondering is that they're going to have
dlc for Damian Wayne to get his Batman
costume because there's a number of
versions of the continuity there's
always like an alternate future version
where you get to see Damien who has
picked up the mantle of the bat after
his father Bruce Wayne has died now
usually he just like a more hardcore
sword-wielding Batman but his costume
looks pretty badass and I know a lot of
people because of the Nightwing news in
the dce you the actual DC movies are
wondering if maybe you know Ben Affleck
wants to leave in a couple years if
they'll just transition Grayson into the
role of Batman there's this big thing
about people taking the Cal I don't know
if they'll ever get to battle for the
cowl in the movies but the thing about
the game that's so cool is the easy just
give the character that skin so you can
kind of do a version of that story life
without having to wait six years to get
to it the other big thing a lot of you
are asking about is that new arkham game
that's supposed to be announced in march
there was like a save-the-date teaser
where everyone's like something really
big is coming from the Arkham people and
then supposedly somebody claiming to be
from the WB Montreal studio who is
leaving his job and it's like I don't
care anymore this is like the reddit
headline so you take it with a grain of
salt said that it's going to be an
insurgency game or like Arkham
revolution where the under
resist Batman's rule in orchestrates a
mass breakout so that might be the basis
for the story of the next arkham game
but they're going to be announcing it
next month anyway so we won't have to
wait that long to find out but here's
like the big bullet points from his big
info dump so to take it with a grain of
salt but he says it's been in
development since 2014 takes place three
years after the events of batman arkham
origins playable characters will include
Batman and Robin with a dick grayson
Robin not Nightwing I know a lot of
people were like maybe Damian Wayne is
going to be Batman in this that was
supposedly going to be a thing but
apparently that's not the case three it
will introduce a new location in Gotham
a coastal area that he claims is
supposed to be the same size as three
islands from Arkham Knight just like a
really big story area for the game
players are supposed to be able to fast
travel between the Batcave and Wayne
Manor the mechanics of the Batmobile
have been completely changed there's no
more battle mode when you're chasing
people combat features are a little more
dynamic that's a no brainer the big
villains include Maximillian Zeus
dollmaker Killer Moth anarchy toothpaste
blockbuster ventriloquist Cornelius Turk
Tweedledee and Tweedledum joost van al
Ghul mad monk dalla Riddler and Joker
and then this last really big one is
kind of weird it's a bit of a
head-scratcher so he says that owl man
is the main villain of the game but then
he also named him alongside the court
about in the talents who are going to be
like these big elite bosses but the
problem is is that a low man is just
earth three Batman so I don't know if
he's talking about talent from DC comics
in mistakenly said element or if it's
genuinely a low man from another
universe has come to our earth so if
this is true at all I think that it's
the Thomas Wayne talent it's not ala man
because you have like all these normal
villains in the single continuity why
would you include somebody from an
alternate universe it doesn't totally
make sense so the person leaking this is
actually being truthful maybe he's not
like a big comic book person he's just a
big games person either way new arkham
game new injustice game they're both
going to be awesome i'll be giving away
copies as we go forward I'm doing
gameplay videos on my game channel
Charlie strings there's a link in the
description for that but i only post a
couple videos a week to that channel but
there is new Deadpool tooth that's
coming up then i'll be posting later
tonight on the main channel as well as a
whole bunch of x-men universe stuff they
explain the future of the x-men universe
and then there's some brand new DC TV
too because they're talking about next
year's for a night cross over but the DC
TV stuff might not post till Monday
because I got game of thrones tomorrow
with walking dead so it's kind of booked
for sunday but there's a new round of
the injustice to give away all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner Willy
Rodriguez please private message me on
the back end of my channel so i can get
your contact details what's going to
happen next is is i'll post that
Deadpool to that should be up in a
couple hours while you wait for that you
can click here to learn all about that
nightly movie that's coming up and you
can click here learn all about iron fist
defenders thank you so much watching
let's that bot I'll see you guys in the
next video